my guest this week is the
singer-songwriter Bjorn elvayas he's one
quarter of Abbott so there's not much
more I need to say to introduce him but
we do talk about what it's like to be
part of one of the biggest pop groups of
all time and how he feels about
performing on stage every night as an
avatar while he's at home in Sweden
having a coffee
[Music]
Bjorn it's lovely to be with you in
person and I feel like we've just been
together because I went to see the Abba
Voyage show but you were a bit further
away and you were an avatar yes and you
you were together with my 79 version yes
I was I I was but but you know you did
say before this show launched it was a
big risk
yeah how do you feel about it now oh I
feel so good about it because it's been
a tremendous success and supposed any
expectations I might have had
you know because
the the the the fact I think the most
important fact of all is that people who
go there
uh don't see the tech but they feel
emotionally connected to these avatars
what were you worried about I was
worried about how the audience would you
know
experience it I I was worried would they
sit there and and look at a video
because it is essentially film
and and that would have been
catastrophic
so the first preview was only like 12
days before we actually opened and and
that's when
we knew the truth
because people did connect is it I mean
do you find it a bit creepy or dystopian
in any way when you when especially for
you looking at yourself your younger
self on stage
um
not creepy but of course when I think
about it it's it's kind of weird
um in a wonderful way
and not dystopian I think unless people
misuse it in the future which we don't
know
but but used for this purpose to tell
this story I I think is wonderful and
how did it work because it's you but
it's been filmed with new clothes your
bodies have got new clothes on I
understand have been they look great
designed by by Dolce Gabbana and the
like how did it actually get created the
avatars as they've been called well
first you do something called motion
capture
it's when you um as the word says you
you capture motion you capture how we
move how we sing and you measure
uh lots of measurements all the
dimensions and the thing is that the
skull apparently doesn't change
the rest of the body falls apart but the
skull Remains the Same
and and so you capture those movements
and you scan the whole body right so
that's what we did for four weeks in
Stockholm the four of us you know
actually performing our songs so you and
is it is it that performance then is
your bodies having been filmed now yeah
but body doubles
right with our movements the body
doubles they emulated our movements
sometimes made them much better and and
then we merged those two things okay and
with the 79 faces
so it's it's a merger between body
doubles motion capture of ourselves and
animation and data-driven animation
creating the faces and what was it like
to be together again I mean I know
you've stayed close
um yeah unlike lots of bands from from
years ago if you've got a good
relationship it sounds like but what was
it like being together doing this again
well it was kind of strange it was
it was a stage and there had lots of
cameras
but it was like
you know doing Dancing Queen
back in the 70s in some TV studio
essentially the same thing but with four
geriatrics
they were happy with that dude
but we had fun doing it I mean we looked
at each other and wow what what is this
is it emotional for you seeing your
younger selves like that you you were in
relationships respectively your lives
were very different yeah
it's it's emotional but but most of all
it's emotional to see how people react
because there's so much
feeling in the room in that Arena it's
it's the right size it's 3 000 but it
feels kind of intimate anyway yeah and
and people are
sometimes crying obviously very moved by
what they see in here
some of that is what we wanted to do and
some of them have come dressed as you oh
yeah yeah yeah in the flares yes and in
the sequence are you quite happy you're
not in the old clothes that you were in
that you've been able to be dressed
slightly differently these are much more
sophisticated and tasteful
some of the stuff that I see that I wore
in the early days like 74 75 I cringe
when I see it now
so but in those days it was the Glam
Rock era yes and everyone tried to look
as outrageous as possible yes and uh
yeah it was a very different style but
it it looks beautiful I mean the only
other thing I thought about it is that I
find uh swedes very straight talking you
sort of say what you think
um I have a Swedish mother a little big
fan and there is something about it
where is it odd that you're showing a
younger version of yourself like why not
have done it as how you are now what do
you we're not trying to hide how we look
now or who we are now it could have been
a film with us acting in it and and but
we decided on concert and we decided it
should be from the 70s
uh that made it much more interesting
to us and I think to the audience as
well then to have ourselves as we are
now performing
um so it was just a decision taking
because we thought it was more
interesting
uh not trying to stay forever young or
anything foolish like that
has it tempted this experience the Abba
Voyage the the performance has it
tempted the four of you to want to go on
tour again
oh no
no way no we toured very very little as
as it is yes we toured like five six
months out of a period of perhaps eight
nine years no I'm just thinking you know
the Rolling Stones keep going yeah they
keep going not you're not thinking any
differently no no
we
we never it was never an attraction for
us too
to go on tour actually yeah well I did
it so little and Anita and I we had
little children we didn't want to yes
leave them
do you think this is a can be seen as a
live gig I'm trying to think about what
you've created is it if it is a new
genre completely or you see it like that
I see it as a live view
as a hybrid live gig
and do you think because the feeling in
the arena is definitely like a live
concert
do you think other bands will follow
suit perhaps the bands that don't speak
to each other
I don't know it's interesting I've been
thinking about this and discussing it
with people who who else can do it who
else is going to follow I'm sure
are some of my contemporaries are
thinking about it right now I don't know
if Mick and Keith perhaps are thinking
about it and and other people as well I
know that there's been talk of Metallica
and and uh
Barry Gibb has been to see it so who
knows
and they asked you any of these no no no
no yeah they just go there and they have
but but it's going to be very
interesting to see someone very creative
be it an artist or a director or someone
will go there and have an idea of how to
take it one step further or
take it in another Direction
um because that's going to happen sooner
or later is there a gig for
from Years Gone by that you never got to
see and you wish you could have done you
wish you could have been that that could
be created by this sort of Technology
um the the Live Aid concert when in in
London
which I think uh the queen biopic is yes
but he would be so complicated to do do
all of these people who appeared there
one single concert well that's a good
one that is a good one this is a good
moment yes but the thing is
we our DNA is in these avatars we've
infused ourselves into them
and you have to be alive to do that yes
I think yeah I was going to ask you
about it because it could become
kind of
speculative
to bring back Elvis yeah it's it's not
doesn't have
the cred that this has because we are
all for in it and that makes the number
of possible acts artists
um less doesn't it it does I mean on
that note because I was going to think
obviously you'd think about the Beatles
perhaps because you know you've still
got obviously said Paul we're currently
performing but could you bring back
others and that you sort of answered
that but would you be happy for this to
continue after you were not here anymore
oh yes you would yes absolutely no it's
part of the Legacy this
this performance this concert and it
will exist well as long as people want
to see it yes okay so so beyond the
grave is fine if you've been there to
make it that's why it's got absolutely
you evolved the bread for that yeah it
must be strange as well sometimes for
you if you're standing in the kitchen I
don't know having a coffee knowing
you're performing
yes you know I know you still live in
Sweden but performing in in the UK yes
every night it's uh it's kind of strange
um of course I've I've been I've
experienced how Mamma Mia the musical
our music was played around the globe
you know almost 24 hours yeah the peak
so but it's not the same as having your
avatar no it's a little bit different
and I I hope the Avatar will appear in
more places than one
quantum physics uh I just I was just in
Singapore
which is a very interesting place to
them for to build
uh if that works out to build a replica
of this Arena oh is that where you're
looking to do it yeah and and um maybe
somewhere in North America as well
okay multiple multiple bjorns right
while you're having that coffee yes yes
what do you do Bjorn if you're at a
party and Abba comes on an ABBA song has
that happened
um I I asked them politely would you
mind playing something else do you yes
and it's like that is kind of weird
and I feel you know when
so I I actually I I zap when I see
myself on TV
well you check you change channels yes I
change channels can't watch it I I don't
know why I don't like watching myself
well most people don't they find that
they do find it hard but I thought maybe
hearing it it might just you might stop
moving well
not
when it's together with other people but
when I when I'm in my car and I hear it
sometimes played on the radio I I I can
listen to it yeah you could drive along
yeah yes at night it and I I have to say
that it sounds
surprisingly fresh a lot of those songs
sound fresh still if you had to turn one
on in the car let's say is there one
that you always go for one of your own
more than 100 to pick from yeah
120 or so
what would I pick
if I had to put one on
I'd probably
I'd probably put on slipping through my
fingers
yeah because it's so
the scene
is so vivid in in in in my memory
from which I wrote the the lyric from
when my daughter went to school okay
waved and was proud and I felt oh
this is her
I'm losing her in a way
she's doing this on on her own and she's
taking her first steps on
and that situation every every parent
knows that it's an interesting time in
music with what makes money what doesn't
make money for new artists coming
through
um there's also if you're at the very
successful end of course which you are
there's the Bob dylans the Bruce
Springsteen is selling their back
catalogs for huge amounts and then
you've got almost on the other side the
Taylor Swift's re-recording their music
so they own them yeah and own the rights
what what do you make of that landscape
with with what's going on and people
selling their rights or keeping them
even closer yeah
uh what isn't clear is exactly what
rights they are selling you know it
seems as though they're divulging up
everything but they're probably not
you know some of them probably have have
continued say in how their songs can be
used and things like that
so but I guess for for older artists and
songwriters
who were really old it might be they
make it easy for their kids
um not to have to inherit it makes it
easier if it's uh if it's cash
um
and and for someone like Taylor Swift
who's in her prime I mean of course he
wants to own everything herself and have
total control over it
and so it's different for different
people yes because I mean you yes we've
talked to you've done other things a lot
of other things now with the music but
you've also been very
um selective highly selective about
who's able to sample yeah or use any of
these yes I mean Madonna was is one of
the only yeah which is one of the few
who was did you have to beg no not beg
but but she she sent um
um the recording with with an assistant
flying over the
Atlantic to Stockholm from you and and
playing it because she didn't want to
send it on by email which I understand
yes and um Benny and I listened and we
don't didn't have to listen more than 45
seconds because it's so brilliant and we
said yes go ahead okay so if it's
brilliant and yeah a few things have
been brilliant Foo Fighters have used
name of the game in one of the songs
brilliantly as well
but that's about the only ones that
we've allowed actually
and and we haven't allowed anything in
commercials or anything like that why
not
um
because I think that that if it's played
in a commercial time and time again it
kind of ruins
a song in a way I think
that's at least how we've reasoned and
and we've had obviously many offers but
we don't know yeah and and you know your
I mean I was also thinking about because
having just seen you in the 70s uh
recently it it's such an unusual band
because of you being in couples as well
I mean I don't know if that has happened
a lot since or before no I don't think I
don't think The Mamas and Papas were two
couples no no no no they weren't
so that there isn't anything like that
two
two
Couples from Sweden
leading everyday boring lives in Sweden
and writing songs
people people ask me why don't you allow
a biopic to be made of you but we said
no so many times
but I I say no it's boy it'll be boring
do you think there's anything about the
fact that you were in these
relationships that that made somebody
said to me is a big fan of your work
that that they felt that you had created
a song for every part of love you know
every almost scenario of Love whether
it's daughters whether it's you know
with your relationship yeah heartbreak
yeah do you think the fact you were
romantically linked had had anything to
do with your ability to tap into those
emotions it might have had
now that you mention it I've never
thought about that but of course
so many facets of life that I
experienced through
us being
socializing as couples yes
and within
agnet is in my marriage and all of that
of course that that inspired I'm sure
that inspired a lot of the lyrics
and and also one important thing is that
uh you know we
we lived in Sweden in Stockholm
and we were two couples
and it it made it very easy to be
disciplined in your work
um
there were you know if we had been a boy
band based in London or New York or L.A
there would have been so many
Temptations yeah
whereas we could be disciplined we could
you know go to work in the morning like
going to the office and write songs all
day treat it like a job yes
yeah and and that's why we were so
productive I think during those years
and we toured so little which is also
good because writing songs is not easy
when you're on tour
so I think that's a
that's one of the secrets behind why
we're sitting here today is that we
we could concentrate on writing so much
is there a song you wish you had written
that someone else's oh that's so so many
so many songs because you probably
listen differently to a lot of people as
well you know hearing what they've done
how they've done it no there's so many
good songs out there
you know my favorite pop song is
probably Ticket to Ride With The Beatles
is it yeah
but there's Hotel California and there's
Ava Maria and there's uh osolomeo
and Smoke Gets In Your Eyes so many
beautiful songs why what is it about
Ticket to Ride
I don't it's it's like a compact little
pop thing that is glittering and and has
the energy and
all the ingredients
maybe it's because I was such a beetle
fan as well yes and also I mean it's
what it goes back to what we're saying
right at the beginning which is you have
your own memories which is why you see
when fans cry when they come to this
concert this experience they'll be
bringing certain thoughts to those songs
that you do because that's what you
associate music yeah with and that's
that's the power of it
um and maybe that you know when I said
about being in the outer World they'll
have a connection point that just comes
comes through
um who are you listening to at the
moment I can't let you go without asking
you that is there someone
it's enough to be new it could be but
you know what phase are you in I am
actually
I haven't had a record player for
I think 40 years but I bought one the
other day a record player and a real
Hi-Fi system an old-fashioned system are
we talking like with vinyl or yes vinyl
yes
and I listened to
um Beethoven's seventh Symphony I was
the that was the last thing I put on
before I came here
so what have you been listening to your
music on until then through your phone
through your devices streaming okay I've
seen them headphones and and
other devices yes fine but how have you
found going back to vinyl all these
years on
because my partner said she wanted it
and I went to one of those shops where
they have it and you sit down in a sofa
and uh and and they play it back to you
Frank Sinatra and stuff like that and
it's
it I don't know it the sound is not
better but it but it there is something
with that something did they know who
you were in the shop oh yeah they did
how did that go down well they feel a
bit of pressure to make sure this went
well the guy was was you know one of
those nerds and he he had to tell me
everything about every speaker and every
player
so he was a bit nervous but he was fun
it was okay and because as I wonder you
you can go about your business without
people bothering you yeah I mean most
people
or many people recognize me but very few
people bother me okay but when they do
do they is it because they need to tell
you something about the song Thank You
For The Music that's it that's it you
did it you set it all up for me you know
it's been such a pleasure talking to you
thank you thank you very much thank you
so much and thank you to you for being
with us until we meet again take care
and goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]